mais retour ici à lons le saunier dans
le jura pour la 20e édition de la percée
du vin jaune l'occasion pour nous de
s'interroger sur la manière dont nos
vignobles ambreuil et en franche-comté
peuvent devenir un argument touristique
avec vous eric avec nos invités
oui avec eux jean charles tissot que je
représente vous êtes le président du
comité interprofessionnel des vins du
jura ain mézières vous êtes gérante de
domaines et châteaux de bourgogne réunis
c'est une maison qui est à beaune enfin
une maison qu'il regroupe plusieurs
maisons d'ailleurs à beaune
patrick ayache vous êtes vice président
du conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté chargé du tourisme et jean pascal
chopard le directeur du comité
départemental du tourisme du jura
alors patrick eya je vous nous disiez
juste avant la pause pour les éditions
régionales que la région souhaitaient un
seul organisme pour communiquer un crt
un comité régional du tourisme
ça veut dire qu'on va vendre de la même
manière et ensemble les vignobles de
bourgogne et du jura exactement là l'une
des premières décisions qu'il fallait
prendre à la fois pour répondre à
l'aspiration enquête vous faisiez
allusion mais aussi pour simplifier
l'organisation de nos territoires
c'est la fusion des deux comités
régionaux du tourisme donc à compter de
fin juin je pense il y aura un seul et
unique organisme de promotion
touristique sur ce territoire et qui va
permettre justement d'unifier nos
stratégies il ya un travail à faire
évidemment pour le pour y arriver est de
promouvoir les deux vignobles de façon
très complémentaires mais jean pascal se
par le disais avant midi les produits
communs aujourd'hui les produits
touristiques communs vendus marche pas
forcément ça du mal à démarrer est ce
que on va répondre à une demande
touristique
écoutez moi mon rêve c'est que désormais
les touristes qui viennent en bourgogne
ou en franche-comté enfin ou dans le
jura eh bien tous avec leur véhicule le
robuste leur train et que nous
organisions des circuits découverte de
cette nouvelle région de telle façon que
c'est
vignoble soient complémentaires et j'ai
vraiment aucun doute sur la capacité de
la région des comités départementaux
mais également de l'ensemble des acteurs
du tourisme de se mobiliser autour de
cet enjeu il ya de nouveaux outils pour
ça on va en parler juste un mot année
s'il vous plaît sur le sur l'importance
finalement de voir des touristes ici
c'est pas seulement pour le plaisir de
voir des chinois des américains ou
d'autres français c'est aussi parce que
ça résonne dans le porte monnaie c'est
un fait il ya un intérêt commercial
puisque nos deux régions jurin et
bourgogne ont les plus forts visite au
caveau et donc d'achat au caveau
directement par rapport aux autres
régions de france nous on est entre 15
15% en tous les cas en bourgogne 15% des
ventes se sont orientés vance ce sont
quelques stations et 1% là pour eux pour
le jura donc c'est exceptionnel les
autres régions sont deux fois moins
importante de gens simples tissot vous
confirmez la relation directe avec les
clients qui peuvent être des touristes
c'est essentiel pour l'économie du
vignoble jurassien ont fait on ne fait
pas de le tourisme pour se faire plaisir
et effectivement peu quand même hein
hein
les yeux la rencontre de plaisir de la
rencontre mais quand on veut mobiliser
les acteurs comme on l'a fait
dans le département du jura je crois
tout faut bien faire comprendre que ya
effectivement de l'économie derrière
l'oenotourisme c'est quelque chose de
fondamental les c'est comme ça qu'on
arrive à mobiliser des acteurs et alors
on est dans une région particulière
parce que la bourgogne du porte la
région bourgogne porte le nombre à la
franche-comté quand le nom d'un fromage
est ce que vous ne souffrez pas en tant
que viticulteur de cette concurrence sur
le plan de la gastronomie locale
en tout cas vins et fromages ça
fonctionne bien oui bien sûr en tout
en tout état de cause le vignoble du
jura peut s'inspirer de ce qu'a fait le
compte et ça c'est la première chose que
le compte est là où c est compté a bâti
une filière extrêmement extrêmement
solide et extrêmement percutant en
termes de communication alors
effectivement on a toujours eu un petit
souci avec la région franche-comté parce
que nous notre vignoble porte le nom de
notre département
c'est pour ça que naturellement on s'est
tourné vers le cdt et vers le conseiller
national par fanta du tourisme en des
avantages que vers la région
franche-comté effectivement on a
toujours eu ce souci
ce souci là même si la région franche
comté nous a toujours soutenus
financièrement dans notre communication
alors il ya quelque chose assez cocasse
c'est que au moment de la fusion des
régions on a demandé à des spécialistes
de marketing territorial
comment il fallait appeler les nouvelles
régions et que pour la bourgogne franche
comté un spécialiste universitaire du
sud de la france a dit bell la meilleure
perception internationale c'est pourquoi
des jurats donc il faudrait si on veut
attirer les gens c'est bourgogne et jura
j'imagine que ça vous ça vous fait
plaisir en tant que responsable du
comité départemental du jura monsieur
sur parra alors effectivement c'est joël
gayet qui avait
exactement elle est réalisée en fait
cette étude là et qui avait montré toute
la puissance de la marque jura aussi
bien pour le tourisme que pour sont sa
marque de territoire sa marque
d'attractivité et c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que nous avions développé un
marketing territorial déjà il ya déjà
plusieurs années avec le comité
interprofessionnel des vins du jura et
réaliser un certain nombre de support
autour de la marque jura
cette filière de nos touristes c'est
aussi un moyen de mutualiser les efforts
de communication
pas seulement en fait sur une approche
touristique monsieur en approche de
marketing territorial de promotion
globale du jura un nouvel outil
important j'imagine pour vous tous et la
cité gastronomique à dijon qui doit
ouvrir ses portes en 2018 10.6 des
trompettes ring
absolument on va en voir quelques images
et en tout cas des maquettes mais on
peut continuer à parler en même temps
qu'elle quel rôle vous allez lui donner
à cette cité gasconne
c'est une initiative du grand dijon que
la région soutient bien entendu il avait
d'ailleurs il ya quelques jours une
première démonstration de ce que cette
cité de la gastronomie allait devenir
n'oublions pas non plus la cité des vins
à beaune et peut-être d'autres
régressive
voilà d'autres initiatives qui vont
naître je crois que on est là on est au
coeur du sujet et que vous voyez en
plein dans le monde urbain
finalement on va pouvoir parler de vin
et gastronomie alors la cité de la
gastronomie à dijon la cité les reins
abonnés ce que le jura les francs
comtois doivent s'émouvoir de cette
situation ils ont ouvert ils vont faire
part à dijon et à beaune on vous avait
parlé du nom de la région il ya quelques
instants je crois qu'il ne faut pas
confondre les marques et le nom de la
région vous savez que la loi fait
obligation région de voter pour leurs
noms avant de voile des glénans l'an
prochain donc
la présidente marie-guite dufay nous a
indiqué hier qu'elle allait lancer une
petite consultation auprès des habitants
sur les réseaux sociaux
voilà c'est un autre débat que celui de
la marque mais c'est un sujet qu'il nous
faudra également abordés
les viticulteurs les attentes ces
grosses structures de promotion
finalement de la gastronomie et des vins
puisqu'on sait que la cité gastronomique
à dijon sa très tournés sur sur le vin
alors oui et c'est essentiel ça fait
partie de notre culture et sera un
rayonnement forcément pour ce qu'ils y
est né et au delà ça pourra aller même
exporter ce savoir faire etc mais c'est
formidable
il ya déjà des contacts pas du tout pour
l'instant avec les organisateurs oui il
y en a un il y en as assez petit à petit
comme tout comme tout bon projet et jean
charles qui sont vous a contacté
l'interprofession du jura pour la cité
gastronomique de dijon où la cité des
gens pourraient jette un coup d'oeil à
mon directeur qui est derrière nous mais
je ne crois pas on va lancer un appel on
va lancer un appel on peut essayer on
peut essayer c'est à dire que pour
l'instant les contacts sont pas établies
mais le virulent encore le triomphe du
jura tout à gagner dans la fusion de nos
deux régions alors je suis pas un souci
là dessus on vous mettra en relation les
rssi se disent président sur la
gastronomie noter que alors c'est pas
tout à fait dans le vignoble mais c'est
quand même une ville jurassienne dole a
été élue capitale de la gastronomie pour
2015 et 2016
en fait on a aussi des distinctions
particulières à ce niveau là avec deux
affaires anciennes gourmand du chat
perché qui a été organisée à dole très
récemment mais est ce que ces grosses
structures sont perçues par vous
professionnels du tourisme de la
viticulture comme de potentiels
locomotive en matière d'attractivité
touristique c'est des éléments
importants c'est d'ailleurs à la fois
des vitrines pour une communication à
l'extérieur c'est d accélérateur de
notoriété
et puis c'est des occasions aussi de
diversifier les buts de visite dans une
zone en données brutes les limites et
ses multiples et les 8es et c'est aussi
affiché en fait une notion d'excellence
sur ces thématiques en fête de la
gastronomie pour que les régions soient
la région bourgogne franche comté soit
situé à un niveau d'excellence sur ces
questions de la gastronomie couple on
sait que la bourgogne natale ans est une
région passage finalement on a du mal à
retenir les touristes
est-ce que ça peut être justement un
moyen de les garder
plus longtemps et leur faire profiter de
nos vignobles qui soir dans le jura ou
en bourgogne
oui je pense effectivement la durée
moyenne des séjours est relativement
courte dans les deux anciennes régions
comment comment arriver à prolonger la
durée de séjour je crois
qu'effectivement en mêlant le tourisme
naturel le tourisme viticole et le
tourisme urbain
c'est une partie de la vocation de la
cité de la gastronomie à dijon
c'est vrai aussi pour besançon et pour d
autres aires urbaines de la région
on doit pouvoir arrivé effectivement
augmenter la durée des séjours en tout
cas il le faut la question se pose
on est dans le symbole mais c'est
important patrick eya c'est ce que la
cité de la gastronomie de dijon va
accueillir l'ancien pavillon de la
passion de la france à l'expo
universelle qui a été fabriquée par une
entreprise franc comtoise est en bois de
franche comté
c'est une idée dont on parle oui c'est
vrai alors je ne sais pas si ça va se
faire mais en tout cas ça d'excédent
symbole de la serbie aux entre dijon et
besançon
ça fait coûté en salle qui se passe que
lons le saunier on va le dire aussi qu
ait candidats une époque pour récupérer
ce pavillon mais voilà on verra dans les
prochains jours voire et peut-être pour
conclure le lot tourisme est ce que pour
l'instant il est plus tourné vers les
domaines vers l'exil de caveaux comme
vous nous disiez tout à l'heure où aussi
vers le tourisme industriel je pense par
exemple au cassis hommes à nuits saint
georges ou est-ce que c'est
complémentaire mais c'est tout un
ensemble de choses le n'autorise comme
on le disait c'est non seulement les
caveaux c'est le vin mais il ya aussi
l'école des vins à beaune qui propose
des formations sur sur le vin des sur
nos vins de bourgogne
il ya des cavistes qui proposent des
dégustations dans bonne c'est tout un
ensemble d'acteurs ou qui tu aimes leur
région est qui et qui ont envie de la
faire aimer encore davantage et le
public d'ailleurs demande aussi une
diversification a des cheveux plus
seulement à les voir une cale il vous
est ce qu'il faut changer de braquet
finalement pour pouvoir proposer une
multitude d'activités aux gens qui
viennent vider nos régions
et je crois que les clients soient
effectivement demandeurs la
problématique du vignoble du jura
aujourd'hui c'est de d'être capable de
d'étoffer cette offre oenotouristique de
la rendre aussi plus qualitatif mais
encore une fois faut pas s'appuyer que
sur les vignerons on peut pas s'appuyer
que sur les vignerons bosnie lisons
amitié doivent commercialisés oui dans
le jura clairement dans le jura
clairement pas encore suffisamment et on
va accueillir tout grand plaisir toutes
les initiatives sur cette thématique
spécifique
c'est une addition le lot tourisme c'est
l'addition d'initiatives autour du vin
voilà un hébergeur qui soit capable de
parler du vigneron qui a trois
kilomètres de chez lui
peut-être de d'accueillir ses hôtes avec
un verre de crémant ou un verre de vin
journe pourquoi pas si ici si ces autres
sont déjà un petit peu familiarisés avec
les vins du jura y peu osé voilà sept cd
des petites choses comme ça c'est une
addition mais voilà encore une fois il
faut mobiliser du monde autour de cette
thématique et au bénin vous opiné non
mais complètement parce que le métier
premier d'un vigneron c'est de faire du
genre c'est le produire de faire du bon
vin bien sûr c'est pas c'est pas
forcément un de commercialiser de
représenter la région voilà il ya des
priorités il faut pas se tromper non
plus de chaque métier ses chevalets pour
chacun d'entre nous on a des priorités
pour bien faire notre métier il faut pas
donc trop se diversifier alors monsieur
chauffard on est ici à lons le saunier
quarante à cinquante mille personnes
sont attendues ce week-end pour la
percée du vin jaune
comment vous professionnels du tourisme
vous fait pour que ces gens reviennent
consommé entre guillemets les structures
touristiques locales
alors on l'est on les incite en fait à
prendre connaissance du département du
jura à travers des outils communication
qu'on met à disposition
et puis c'est aussi à cette occasion là
la possibilité de proposer des séjours
proposer des séjours à l'occasion de
cette manifestation là pour que les
visiteurs restent plus longtemps on
revient sur cette notion de durée
moyenne de séjour qui est très faible
fac est plutôt assez faible chez nous et
c'est une occasion cette manifestation
la d'allonger et de créer un motif
devenu dans le vignoble
alors que on est plutôt sur la partie
montagnes du jura en fait à cette époque
là de l'année et donc ça c'est une
occasion de consommation supplémentaire
dans le vignoble
j'ajouterai que les restaurateurs ont un
rôle clé à jouer dans cette filière de
lolo tourisme mais ça tombe bien parce
qu'on arrive à l'heure du déjeuner merci
à tous les quatre et à 0 prince qui
était là dans la première partie de
l'émission
merci eric bonne percée du vin jaune
main à tous vos antennes